Rex Tillerson two top staff members and
his State Department deputy are
following him out the door this morning
the fired Secretary of State says
President Trump never spoke to him
before revealing his decision on Twitter
major Garrett is at the White House
where another high-level shuffle may be
coming major good morning good morning
the firing of Rex Tillerson has deepened
the sense of anxiety about who is next
to go in the Trump administration inside
the White House speculation persists
that National Security Adviser HR
McMasters days are numbered with john
bolton possibly waiting in the wings
congressional sources say housing
secretary ben carson and veteran's
secretary david Shulkin are both in
serious jeopardy President Trump said
yesterday he is quote very close to
having the cabinet and other things that
he wants with Mike Mike Pompeo we have a
very similar thought process I think
it's going to go very well
president Trump believes Mike Pompeo
will be more in line with his foreign
policy agenda than outgoing Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson who clashed with the
president over two big nuclear issues
the deal with Iran and possible talks
with North Korea when you look at the
Iran deal I think it's terrible I guess
he fit it was okay I wanted to either
break it or do something and he felt a
little bit differently as a former tea
party congressman Pompeo advocated for
rolling back the Iran deal I think the
science needs to continue to develop a
climate change skeptic Pompeo previously
criticized the Paris climate Accord
Tillerson unsuccessfully lobbied mr.
Trump to honor the agreement I received
a call today from the president states
at Lowell after noontime from Air Force
One yesterday a visibly shaken Tillerson
never mentioned the president by name
did not thank him and took no questions
the undersecretary at the State
Department Steve Goldstein said
Tillerson was quote unaware of the
reason for his dismissal and had every
intention of staying the White House
fired Goldstein after seeing the
statement in a private burst of anger
last July Tillerson reportedly called
mr. Trump a [ __ ] the relationship
already rocky never recovered mr.
from snap decision last week agreeing to
meet with North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un froze out Tillerson I made that
decision by myself Forex wasn't as you
know in art in this country about the
Secretary of State to be Pompeo he
learned early on the key to a solid
working relationship with President
Trump was constant visibility so he took
on the task of providing the president's
daily intelligence briefing Pompeyo is
also highly regarded by the Republican
majority in the Senate which should make
his confirmation Gail even in a midterm
election relatively smooth all right
major Garrett we will all be watching
I tell you watching those departures and
firings in the White House in the
cabinet looks like the March Massacre by
President Trump I look at his March
Madness there's a March Madness on the
basketball court and there seems to be a
March Madness at the White House and
Donald Trump has always said he likes
people to disagree
he likes chaos yeah it does not seem to
live to a point only up to that point is
right